so World building is another kind of
speculative Futures approach this is an
image from the movie Minority Report
which is set around the time frame of
2050-ish and to build the world the
filmmakers had to research what 2050-ish
could be like it wasn't just about
looking into the technologies that could
happen it was also about diving into
what political systems might be like
what are the ecological contexts what
are the cultural norms and the flood was
so successful at grounding what at the
time were really Fringe areas of
research responsive targeted advertising
or touch screen tag like that wasn't
around when it came out in the early
2000s that it led to hundreds of patents
in the years since because we could
really see how these things might impact
daily life
these days some speculative features are
designed to be experiential in digital
form this example is from bidibon for
slate which is a VR exploration of a
climate change Toronto by the First
Nation artist Lisa Jackson so as you put
on these VR goggles you explore what
Toronto could be it's hotter it's wetter
and you also hear the languages of
different First Nation people the wendot
the Ojibwe the Mohawk as you're moving
through this world so you're connecting
to different aspects of its past it's
present as you are also exploring its
future
another approach is design fiction these
are typically ways of creating
prototypes of tools that occur in a
given scenario what Sanders showed us at
the beginning is very much a design
fiction another example that I love is
called ayapa repository and it's a 2016
effort by two artists ayodamolo
acostende and salomeya Sega and they
made basically a museum and a resource
library of objects that affirm the
futures of black people so they got
together with some different community
members they brainstormed what some of
these objects might be that can support
black life in coming years and then they
made them into objects so very much from
like the afrofuturism tradition of doing
this work another speculative Futures
tactic is speculative design which is
basically a form for using design to
challenge assumptions about current
conditions and Convention this
particular project is hyphen lab's
neurospeculative afrofeminism Salon
which re-envisions a black hair salon as
a lab for neuro cosmetology and
cognitive enhancement so again
challenging the idea of what a black
hair salon can be and doing it in high
resolution fashion
some speculative Futures use more simple
tactics
this is a project by the artist candy
Chang she did a series after Hurricane
Katrina in New Orleans in the mid 2000s
and she covered buildings that had been
made Vincent and abandoned After the
Storm occurred she covered them with
these stickers asking people to add
their ideas of what they wish those
buildings were instead and its
Simplicity gets to the heart of really
what speculative Futures are all about
their means of asking what if and why
not what else can exist here in place of
what is right now
so the process of proactively engaging
with the future and these personal high
resolution tactile ways is something
that researchers find increases are
resilience as individuals and as
societies the more we imagine what the
future can be the stronger our abilities
to engage with longer time frames become
the more we do that the more we look
into longer time frames the more
frequently we end up challenging
assumptions and current conventions the
more we challenge those assumptions the
more that our senses of autonomy and
resilience start to expand so doing this
work can make us more resilient on
individual levels
the more we imagine the future together
the more socially resilient we often
become social resilience is essentially
a different community's ability to adapt
cope deal with different kinds of Social
and environmental hazards and
researchers are finding that just as
important as ecological and
infrastructural resiliences social
resilience is just as critical this
picture
is an image of Chicago's 1995 Heatwave
which killed hundreds of people across
the city and researchers have found in
the decades since that communities that
whether the event more safely where less
people died were those where people knew
each other they were socially resilient
because they were socially connected so
while infrastructural resilience for
example can take large amounts of time
and money to achieve social resilience
are connections to each other the
institutions that hopefully support us
is a more immediate opportunity that
still has very real impact
so researchers have found that stronger
degrees of collaboration and reciprocity
are an effective means of enhancing that
aspect of social resilience so
collaboration is a way of deepening
trust and connection also lays the
groundwork for self-determination all of
which can be very critical to enhancing
resilience
so speculative Futures tactics help us
do this work help us build these
Connections in a few different ways one
is by cultivating possibility through
play
so one example of what this can look
like is a project called the Republic of
Columbus being and it was an effort that
was led by an artist named Jorge Manos
Rubio while he was working in Columbus
spring which is a neighborhood in West
Amsterdam
so residents in the area come from a lot
of different cultures which has resulted
in some conflict over the years and
after trying some more traditional
measures to address these issues local
government asked different artists and
designers to try some more experimental
tactics so Manos Rubio worked with
residents in the area to come up with
the idea of turning the local square
into a micronation so even though he was
the one who came up with this initial
concept of creating a micronation he
used speculative Futures tools to invite
The Wider Community to inhabit it and
explore what it meant to create this
alternative reality in the moment
so they use speculative features tactics
to invite different members of the
community into this process they made
their own money passport stamps design
fictions they created a National Space
Agency they visited the actual European
space agency but they also came back to
Columbus being to the micronation of
Columbus Spain and used Tyvek kites to
test out what their own future rocket
launches could be
they created their own Olympic sports
teams so as the months progressed
the square became a sanctioned
micronation acknowledged in Amsterdam
but also by other micronations worldwide
it was a place where residents could
start to imagine that they were citizens
of their own shared nation state and
live out the ramifications of doing so
in real time
so this was a kind of play this was an
experimentation and it was also a way of
stepping again temporarily out of the
conflict Zone that was this present
State between people who had a lot of
differences with each other and it
wasn't about ignoring the fact that
those differences existed it was about
saying what else can also exist here and
then creating a space to work through
and have collaborative discussion about
what else that could be in creating
trust to different degrees in the
process this is not to say that this
solved all of Columbus beans issues
because it did not but it was again a
way of cultivating new degrees of trust
I shared identity and a certain sense of
belonging
so speculative Futures also invite us to
not just think about the future but to
use our senses in order to feel it
and that can be a way of making the
future I feel like a really personal
place so this is a shot from a 2017
project called the Future Energy lab
created by the studio superflex for the
government of the United Arab Emirates
superflex created a series of
interactive experiential Futures
installations with the goal of
influencing the country's energy
policies so they identified five
different energy scenarios that could
occur in the country up to the year 2050
and they made an energy simulator
role-playing game different interactive
objects so that different decision
makers the Prime Minister was involved
the head of cabinet they could explore
what these different Energy Futures
would be again by feeling into and
exploring in tactile ways with the
ramifications could go down as
so in one scenario people got to smell
the air that might occur if current
fossil fuel emissions rates continued so
it was a pretty noxious mix of carbon
monoxide nitrous oxide it smelled like
rotten eggs and it was an experience
that allowed people to not just think
about air quality in the future but to
really feel it to experience it I'm
borrowing a phrase from Stuart candy
who's a long now fellow and a former
colleague of mine that speculative
Futures this work helps us to not just
see into the future but feel into the
future and when we do so we can start to
really relate to the Future as a
fundamentally personal place which it
really is we will be living some of us
at least 30 years from now our children
our grandchildren will be living there
the speculative features can also be a
powerful way of balancing between the
parts of our brain that work with
long-term vision and other parts that
are more focused on the here and now
because speculative Futures tools really
focus on different narrative aspects
that can be a way of again linking the
specific and the personal to initiate
the balance between these two time
frames